>> LAST NIGHT FLORIDA REPUBLICA
CONGRESSMAN BYRON DONELSON
SPARRED WITH FOREIGN LEFT
LUNATIC OVER IT MST AND C OR NB
HOST JOY READ AS AND IT SHOWED
AS WHAT HE SUCH A RISING STAR
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> YOU NOT BELIEVE THE IDEA WAS
TO MAKE A DIVERSITY STATEMENT B
DOMINATING YOUR?
>> FIRST, THAT WAS NOT THE IDEA
THAT WAS IN THE ROOM BY DECISIO
MADE.
>> IS STILL NOT EXPLAIN HOW YOU
LAST--SPARE YOU CAN LET ME
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION?
NUMBER TWO LET'S GO BACK THE
REALITY IS A LOT OF MEMBERS DO
BELIEVE IN MY ABILITY TO LEAD.
AND MIKE TO BE DESPISED FOR MY
GOOD BECAUSE I'VE SERVED ONE
TERM?
MY MEMBERS OF THE ABILITY TO
ENGAGE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
CONFERENCE.
IT'S EVEN BIGGER THAN THAT.
WILL BRENNAN ANN PASSED LAST
WEEK.
WE GOT THAT DONE KEVIN MCCARTHY
IS NOT SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
>> ON VOTING LAWS YOU VOTED YOU
DEFEND VOTING LAWS THAT SAID
GETTING RID OF BELLA HARVESTING
IS A GOOD THING THAT WE DID SAV
DEFENDED THAT LITTLE BOARDING
LAWS.
YOU'VE ACTUALLY--SB MET THE
FLOAT ABUTTING LOGIC.
>> AND BE MET THE LAST NEW YORK
WE DO IT THE BEST.
>> OF COURSE JOY READ AS A
HISTORY OF THESE TYPES OF SMEAR
TACTICS.
NBC STANDBY THIS?
IS ANOTHER SMALL SAMPLE TAKE A
LOOK.
>> I THINK EVEN THOUGH WE
INTELLECTUALLY STAND UNDERSTAND
WHAT AMERICA IS ON ITS BASE
THERE IS A GREAT AMOUNTS OF
RACISM ANTIBLACK ANTI- WOKE
NESTS.
>> BEING A FREELOADER AND A
SELFISH AND DISRESPECTFUL WHEN
EVER BLACK VERNACULAR FROM ELON
MUSK IS THE ABSOLUTE WORST THEY
REVEALED A PRETTY RADICAL
DISPARITY IN HIQ HUMAN
UKRAINIANS LOOK AND FEEL TO
WESTERN MEDIA.
COMPARED TO BROWN OR BLACK OR
COUNTERPARTS.
>> IF SOMEHOW MANAGED TO STUMBL
INTO THE SUPREME COURT, TO ANY
OF YOU GUYS TRUST UNCLE CLARENC
IN A BE CONNIE BAER WRITTEN
THOSE GUYS ACTUALLY FOLLOW THE
LETTER TIM SCOTT STANDING OVER
THAT ROUND OF WORDS AND A BASKE
FULL WORDS.
>> SADLY, THE POLITICS OF
PERSONAL DESTRUCTION HAS NOTHIN
THOUGH FROM THE LEFT.
DONALD'S WIFE ERICA IS NOW
SHINING A LIGHT AND THE ATTACKS
THAT THEY BOTH RECEIVED FROM
UNHINGED THAT LIBERAL AGITATORS
IT TWEETING QUOTE BYRON AND I
HAVE BEEN TOGETHER FOR 23 PLUS
YEARS.
MOST MOST RACIST ATTACKS WE
EXPERIENCED ARE ALWAYS FROM THE
LEFT.
THEY CAN ACCEPT A FREETHINKING
BLACK MAN ACHIEVED A SUCCESS ON
HIS OWN MERITS AND THEY SURE AS
HECK CAN'T STAND HE MARRIED TO
ME.
CRY HARDER HATERS.
CONGRESSMAN BYRON DONELSON HIS
WIFE.
I THINK YOU NEED TO JOIN HIM IN
CONGRESS AND THE SENATE.
IN POLITICS L OBJECT WE IN YOUR
RIGHT.
I'VE GOT TO YOUR HUSBAND IF HE
IS A NATURAL BORN LEADER IN THE
GREAT STORY AND TERMS OF
PERSONAL SUCCESS.
HAVE YOU GOTTEN ON A REACTION T
THAT MARK DEFINITELY MORE
REACTION THAN EXPECTED.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU HAVING
ME ON BUT THE TRUTH IS WHAT YOU
SAID THE HUSBAND IS A NATURAL
WIND LEADER HE IS THE FUTURE OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY'S
COLLEAGUES IN CONGRESS AND KNOW
WHAT HIS COLLEAGUES FROM THE
FLORIDA HOUSE KNOW IT.
PEOPLE WHO WORKED WITH HIM IN
HIS CAREER IN FINANCE AND KNOW
IT I CERTAINLY KNOW IN MY BOYS
DO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THOSE ON
THE OTHER SIDE TRIED THEY ARE
THE ONES TRYING TO IGNITE HIM
AND SAY THAT THE ONLY REASON HE
SUCCESSFUL IS BECAUSE THE COLOR
OF ITS CAM OR BECAUSE OF WHO HI
WIFE IS IN COLOR OF MY SKIN WE
ALL KNOW IT'S NOT TRUE WHEN HE
HAS ACHIEVED HIS SUCCESS BY HAR
WORK MAYOR AND INTELLIGENCE I'M
SO PROUD OF HIM.
>> AND YOU SHOULD BE.
IF GOTTEN TO KNOW YOU.
I FIND IT AN HONOR AND LOVE YOU
LIFE'S STORY.
YOU LOOK AT JOY READ I WAS
SURPRISED HE WENT ON OUR SHOW.
GIGI IS THE TERM UNCLE CLARENCE
ABOUT CLARENCE THOMAS.
SHE ONCE SUGGESTED THAT THE GOP
HAS HATRED FOR BIDEN BECAUSE HE
WAS THE VICE PRESIDENT TO A
BLACK PRESIDENT.
SHE ONCE SAID EDUCATION THE
ISSUE IS A CODE FOR WHITE
PARENTS WHO DON'T WANT RAISE IT
TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS.
MAYBE SHE FORGOT JOE BIDEN
PARTNERED WITH A FORMER KLANSMA
HIM TO STOP INTEGRATION OF
PUBLIC SCHOOLS APPEAR PURITY DO
NOT WANT SCHOOLS TO BE A RACIAL
DONGLE.
SHE ALSO SAID PEOPLE ON THE
RIGHT WOULD TRADE ALL THE TAX
CUTS FOR THE ABILITY TO OPENLY
SAY THE N-WORD.
WHERE DID SHE GET THIS FROM?
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO NBC?
>> I DON'T REALLY PAY MUCH
ATTENTION TO WHAT JOY SAYS I
THINK GOING ON THE SHOW WAS MOR
ABOUT BRINGING THE IDEAS AND
CONSERVATISM TO ALL BOATERS AT
SOMETHING THAT WILL MY VOTERS I
BACK IN SOUTHWEST FLORIDA I WAS
GOING TO DO.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM DOING THOSE
INTERVIEWS BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT ALL AMERICANS
HEAR THE IDEAS THAT
CONSERVATIVES A PUSH AND WE
BELIEVE THEM.
IT'S BEEN THE THING THAT'S MADE
AMERICA THE BEACON OF LIGHT
ACROSS THE WORLD.
I'M NOT AFRAID OF THE TOUGH TAL
WITH ABOUT ALSO BECAUSE OF
THAT'S WHAT'S NECESSARY FOR
REPUBLICANISM AND CONSERVATISM
IMPORTANTLY TO SUCCEED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> HOW YOU FEELING ERIC HAASE
NOW THAT YOUR HUSBAND HAS BEEN
IN CONGRESS AND IS IN CONGRESS
AND NOW EMERGED AS A LEADER THE
ATTACKS SEEM TO ESCALATE HOW AR
YOU OKAY WITH THAT WE HAVE THIC
SKIN YOU MIGHT NOISE SERVED ON
THE SCHOOL BOARD AND A LOCAL
COUNTY.
THAT'S THE WORST PLACE TO GET
TACTICS MAQAMAT INVESTIGATED AS
DOMESTIC TERRORIST.
>> ARE DEFINITELY IN ONE OF THE
ACTIVE PARENTS OF BYRON AND I
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS FIGH
FOR OVER TEN YEARS.
MEMBERS OF THE TEA PARTY
MOVEMENT CONSERVATIVES IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
WE ARE NO STRANGER TO THE BATTL
AGAINST THE LEFT AND WE ARE
AFRAID OF THEM.
IT TAKES LEADERS LIKE BYRON TO
GO ON MSNBC AND CNN AND BATTLE
THEM WITH IDEAS WITH POLICIES
WITH FACTS IN THAT THE WORLD
KNOW WE ARE NOT AFRAID TO, WITH
THE RECEIPTS EVEN SHOW AMERICAN
THE TRUTH ABOUT THEIR POLICIES
AND THE IMPACT OF THEM.
>> A PERSON OF A GAVE THAT UP O
THE MALL AFTER I WENT ON THE
VIEW WITH ROSIE O'DONNELL.
A TOTAL WASTE OF MY TIME.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR BEING
WITH US.